is there anybody who you're gonna geek
out if you get to me tonight ooh
ariana grande here same-same ariana
grande how're the extensions just for
her I know I'm such a fangirl it's like
you know so anybody I see I'll probably
just be like okay play it cool play it
cool we've got this Janna this is a
musical night I mean now's your chance
do you have a rap you want to share
about how it feels to be here
I know right now absolutely not I'm
pretty sure there's actual real rappers
here who would be like she's got to go
she's gotta go so I can't ruin it well
it's been you know a whole 24 hours ish
it's been a couple days since we found
out that you are single and available
has anyone slid into the DMS especially
from bachelor nation cuz those boys do
that I haven't had the chance to scroll
still I've been really busy but I feel
like you're not saying something we'll
see let's see who slid into the DM Santa
there's just been a few like random once
I haven't replied yet though I think I'm
still trying to take things in and
figure things out you know anyone we
would know maybe someone from bachelor
nation maybe is it Dean know how I know
how happy are you with your new man I am
I'm so happy it feels so good he's great
he's so supportive and you know he's not
afraid of the bachelor world which is
good too because he supports me like hey
babe I have to watch this he's like yeah
turn it on I'm like okay good like it's
basically part of my job and so have you
talked to Colton and Cassie at all
they've kind of come out and the whole
thing happens I have it
I heard Instagram shut down yesterday so
I missed a lot of their stories and
stuff but they do seem really happy so I
am very happy for them alright last
chance Paradise
um not opposed it's not opposed
[Music]